now that apple finally released their
magsafe battery pack
for iphone 12s is it the better choice
compared to anker's powercore magnetic
5k
even though it costs 55 dollars more of
course
it's actually mac safe right well not so
fast
in my detailed testing i found big
differences
including two things that i haven't
heard anybody mentioned yet on the
internet
one of which could make or break the
purchasing decision of about 60 percent
of you
both of these have their pluses and
their minuses but if you watch through
this video i will help you make the
correct choice
of which one you should buy as well as
if you should upgrade to apple's magsafe
pack
if you already own a different one since
i already mentioned prices let's start
out with that
apples comes in at 99 and increase has
an msrp of just
under half of that i purchased mine for
about 45 bucks on amazon
but now that apples is out i would bet
that the price will drop even lower
depending on when you're watching this
video so you can check out the prices
using the link in the video description
as far as size apple's mac save pack
takes the win footprint wise anchors is
slightly smaller but it's also thicker
and heavier
and looking at pictures online it really
is hard to tell but putting them side by
side
you can see the anchors is about 45
thicker than apples
weight wise anchors isn't that much
heavier coming in at about 17
more but we definitely have a bigger
difference comfort wise
because anchors is more boxy while the
edges are rounded they're not as curved
as apples which means it digs into your
hand more when you're holding it
i wouldn't say that it's so bad that
it's a deal breaker like i had with my
big gray charger but it's definitely
worth considering both use hard plastic
for their shelves but ankurus is a bit
more grippy which along with its boxy
design
helps it stay more secure in your hand
on the magnet side anker doesn't change
its material
where apple added a silicone pad which
improves grip to the phone
that along with the slightly stronger
magnets means that the apple pack stays
more securely attached to your phone
it's not a massive difference as the
magsafe pack can still easily be twisted
and popped off
but it is an improvement overall apple's
design is sleeker and more simple
there is a single led light that turns
on when something is happening
sometimes when it's not actually even
charging whereas
ankurus has four lights for showing you
the capacity and one more to show you
the status
like if it's on if it's charging or
charging something
and if the device isn't properly working
a huge benefit with apple's pack is the
fact that you don't have to press a
power button first
to make sure that it's on to charge your
phone in fact there is no power button
it just turns on automatically when you
attach it
and it transfers data to your phone
because of this it's also able to show
you how much it's charged in your
battery widget
and if it's actively being charged or
charging your phone
with that the phone can also choose to
stop the charge if it needs to
and unfortunately at this time there is
one use case
where flat out won't charge your phone
and to me
it is really frustrating because that is
one time where i
really want a portable battery pack to
keep my battery topped off
but apple's pack does not do that and
that is
when you are gaming which is one task
which really drains your battery i
started off using a fully charged iphone
12 that had optimized charging turned
off
and my max 8 battery pack was at 50
percent and i played call of duty mobile
for 30 minutes and during that time
my iphone's battery dropped to 90
percent and if you know how iphones work
they show 100 for way longer than other
ones so that is exaggerated
during that time the magsafe battery
pack wasn't used at all
to keep the phone charged which is what
many people say is the point of these
kind
of wireless charging packs after that i
played another 30 minutes using
anker's pack and during that time i
didn't lose
any of the charge on my iphone 12 and
ended with the same amount that it
started with so it was basically drawing
power from the wireless charger
and not the phone itself which is what i
wanted this same thing could also apply
to other scenarios that drain your
battery
a lot like photo video editing and other
tests as well
now i understand that apple may not want
the heat from the phone to be added to
the heat from the battery pack
but many people including myself plug in
our phones into wall power when we're
gaming
and that also heats up our phones and
can even cause screen
dimming because of heat and when ankers
was powering my phone and i was gaming i
didn't have an issue and the screen
didn't dim
any it was just set to its 80 percent so
if you're a gamer and you want to draw
power from a pack
the anchor seems to be a lot more
flexible i will be researching
this issue much more in my detailed full
review so click that subscribe button
down below if you guys want to see that
and with that you can help us reach our
goal of a million subscribers before the
end of the year
we would greatly appreciate it now let's
get into the charging speed and capacity
where we have some massive
differences right out of the gate
anker's pack is rated at a standard 5
000 milliamp hours whereas apple shows a
measly 1460
but that doesn't tell the whole story
apple is doing something
very unique and that is using batteries
that have a voltage of 7.62
compared to 3.6 in anchors and pretty
much every other battery bank
if we do the math the equivalent
milliamp hours
at 3.6 volts would be 2 920
much better than 1460 but still less
than
60 percent of the anchor's capacity but
we also have to factor in charging
and circuitry efficiency which is where
my detailed real world testing comes in
i personally was super excited about
apple coming out with their own maxwell
pack
because of much faster charging than
regular qi charging
and this one is rated at 15 watts
compared to only five with anchors
and it can provide close to that if
you're using it
for pass-through wireless charging now
you actually get about 9.5 usable watts
of wireless charging to the iphone's
battery
which is slower than 12.5 with apple's
dedicated puck
but that's still much faster than
increased 5 watts of pass-through
charging
so your iphone will charge about twice
as fast if you're using it as a wireless
charging base
but unfortunately if you are using it on
the go without being plugged into the
wall
it will also only provide 5 watts
just like anchors which ruins the
biggest reason why i personally wanted
a genuine magsafe pack from apple now i
was still a bit
optimistic because apple's higher
voltage and efficient coil and circuitry
could mean that we might still get
faster speeds and better efficiency
so let's go ahead and see just how much
charge this thing can provide
compared to anker's cheaper solution i
tested with a practically new iphone 12
and started with it fully dead
apple's pack took three and a half
minutes to turn the phone on which
seemed good
but anchors did so faster at three
minutes after 15 minutes my iphone 12
reached 9
charge where anchors reached 10 percent
and after 30 minutes maxsafe was still
one percent behind at 18
compared to 19. skipping to the one hour
mark apple's pack
got us to a measly 36 percent and
anchors
still one percent ahead at 37. i have to
pause and say that these speeds are
really disappointing
if apple had actually allowed full max
save speeds the iphone 12 would reach
this amount in 35 minutes instead of an
hour
and with that it still seems like
apple's 5 watt charging
isn't any more efficient than anchors
after an hour and 30 minutes apples
reaches
53 and after 1 hour and 45 minutes
it's at 57 percent compared to anchors
59
showing that that one is still slightly
ahead and that is where another level of
disappointment came
because this is where apple's max safe
pack was completely
drained meaning your iphone 12 will only
get
57 extra charge from this 99
pack and it will take a long time to get
there and of course with the iphone 12
for max it will be
much lower than that anchor kept going
until it reached 87 percent
charge so we get an additional 30
capacity for an iphone 12 compared to
apple spec
and about 52 more usable overall
wireless charging capacity this shows us
that although magsafe might be more
efficient in the way the apple
doesn't have to use as large of a
battery cell because of the higher
voltage
the overall real-world charging
efficiency isn't that much better
and if you're only trying to reach 50
charge anchors could do that faster
and then at the same time it can charge
while you're doing intensive tests
with that how long do these take to
charge well apples is fairly quick
since it accepts 15 real world watts
through its lightning connector
compared to 9.5 and because the battery
is smaller
if you're only charging it by itself it
will complete in an hour and 15 minutes
compared to 3 hours and 15 minutes with
anchor so if you want to quickly charge
before going somewhere apple definitely
takes the win there's also a few other
differences that you have to know about
before choosing which one to buy first
off the mac safe pack uses a lightning
connector to charge
which can be more convenient if you
don't use usb type-c
but it doesn't come with a cable like
anchors does because of this the only
way you can charge
a device is by using wireless charging
not
wired and if you're not charging an
iphone 12
just like apple's 40 maxsafe puck in
regular qi charging mode it will only
output between 2.5 to 3.3 watts
so if you want to charge a friend's
older iphone or an
android phone anker will be able to
charge it about twice as fast and the
same thing goes with charging airpods
it will take about six hours to charge
airpods pro
with apple's pack compared to about
three and a half hours with anchors
with that the lighting port can't output
power at all whereas anker's usb type-c
port is rated at 10 watts so if you have
a cable with you your airpods can charge
in two hours
or the times that you really care about
charging speed and capacity
the anchor pack can be used as a regular
power bank
and give you a full 100 charge and
much faster than wireless charging as
well of course
most people are not buying these for
that they would just buy a regular power
bank
but i have to say that it is nice having
the extra flexibility
to also be able to bring for example an
apple watch charger or
top off other phones or other devices
the last thing that i have to mention
is reverse wireless charging since it's
been in the headlines
for me this feature is practically
worthless after i started testing it
for a number of reasons the only benefit
that you can get is if you accidentally
plug
in your phone instead of the pack and
you're charging overnight then you will
actually charge it up
but other than that it's pretty much
useless and i'll cover this in a lot of
detail in my full review
overall if you don't care about capacity
and flexibility
and you don't already have a mac safe
puck or another wireless charger at home
that you use for your phone
and you want to have this thing as a
base station overnight
or if you really care about branding and
long-term reliability and just knowing
that you have an apple device that
should be reliable
then i would say you probably would be
better off buying anchors
it is less than half the price it is not
that much heavier
and slightly less comfortable but better
grip
it can still pass through charge and it
has a lot more flexibility overall
but you guys let me know which one you
would rather buy down in the comment
section below
click that circle above to subscribe
help us reaching a million subscribers
that would be amazing
check out one of those great videos
right over there this been max and i
will see you
in the next video
[Music]
you